[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني حزب البعث بس حزب البعث الى قاعده
شعبيه كبيره في العراق
راح احكي عن العراق اللي هو المضمار
مضماري اللي نتكلم عنه
يلاقوني اشخاص عمرهم 17 سنه
ست
احنا نحبكم اني حزبي اقول له يابا انت ايش
كبرك وصرت حسبي يعني احنا من طلعنا من
الحكم
نعطيك اياه كمثل
والحزب فكر كبير
والى بصمه على الساحه
ما ينتهي الفكر بانتهاء
الاشخاص يتوارثون الفكر هذا من شخص الى
شخص ينتقل
لكن ما يموت الفكر لا يحس بالبعد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حزب البعث يعني
في اشخاص كثر وكلهم مؤمنين به اما ان لانه
حتى نكون اوضح للمستمع اللي راح يقول لا
هم شلون اكو يعني يمكن كذا يقال انه اكو
خلاف هذا طبيعي
كل مرحله
تليها مرحله اجدد
يحدث شيء من الخلاف او الصراع اني مو
بينهم الله اعلم شنو دا يصير بينهم يعني
مستنده الى ان سمعت شيء منهم
[موسيقى]